I love going to India.
I'm always excited by the great progress the country is making.
More children are surviving and thriving...
...and getting access to improved education.
Millions of families have been lifted out of poverty.
India has a very innovative workforce,...
...resourceful and optimistic about the future.
They're finding ingenious ways to reduce poverty and hunger,...
...improve access to health care, financial services...
...clean water and sanitation.
During my visits,...
...I get to see health workers, teachers, scientists and politicians.
It takes all those different groups to pull these solutions together.
So I love the energy and the learning I get every time I'm there.